hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and just checking in on you I'm
checking it out you eyes your eyes your
eyes your [ __ ] week going yeah you
know it's a weird week right let's
[ __ ] stressful if you're a college
kid you take it finals you know if you
mug people you know I don't know
everybody's shopping online so they're
not really carrying a big box like back
in the day all right I feel bad for
people used to steal people's [ __ ]
Christmas packages
it's another dying industry out there
every year just sitting there in the
[ __ ] bushes right like one of them
goddamn lions trying to catch a [ __ ]
baboon just sitting there when it's too
[ __ ] many on my knee one one person
to kind of stray from the herd and I'll
grab them and all the other baboons will
scream for a second but they'll know
it's too late oh [ __ ] I watched a bunch
of [ __ ] up you ever just watch videos
of animals killing each other you know
and then you just get to that one and
you're like it's just so [ __ ]
horrific you know you almost want to
just call up PETA and be like really you
got nothing on this one I didn't watch
it thank God I didn't watch it I just
shut it off really quickly but there was
these [ __ ] baboons right I don't know
what it is about monkeys but I loved
seeing him get killed I have to there's
a few things that I don't mind seeing
get killed monkeys are one of them I
don't like them I like gorillas but
everything else everything that they can
go [ __ ] themselves it's weird you know
cuz I'm you know mostly a [ __ ] ape
myself as everybody else maybe more
monkey I don't know I have no idea so
these [ __ ] baboons right they sit
there and they you know I guess they
come down from the trees I thought they
ate bananas you know I get a lot of my
you know a lot of my animal statistics
on you know old-school Hollywood and
what they had them do I thought they
just sat around eating [ __ ] bananas
and dancing to some old guy crank in a
music box but evidently they come down
from the trees and they like they I
don't know they're in the grass they're
doing something right so they're always
next to these little impalas of these
gazelles and I'm not talking about the
car the sneakers I'm talking about the
animals here right so they're [ __ ] do
you know just be grazing along and then
all of a sudden they just out of nowhere
they're just like you know I [ __ ] this
I'm sticking in this grass I could use a
protein shake and they'll just [ __ ]
sort of subtly just start walking behind
one of the little baby gazelles and if
they can they'll [ __ ] snatch it and
then these [ __ ] lunatics they like
they won't kill it they just start
pulling the thing apart just nonchalant
I was just [ __ ] uh I saw the picture
and I couldn't click on it so I always
sick of that [ __ ] you don't I mean I
liked when Tim pansies fight each other
they [ __ ] rip the yellow chimps foot
off and yank his [ __ ] balls off I'm
just like you know I don't know but
there's got to be some good ones because
human beings do horrible [ __ ] to each
other but you know it doesn't mean they
should all [ __ ] die right stupid they
should have some sort of like court
system among the gazelle and baboon
[ __ ] mech I say that's a [ __ ]
serial killer right someone would just
sit [ __ ] eating grass and this one
just he just went rogue definitely
wasn't you know speaking of which what
do you see what this [ __ ] impossible
burger I had one it tastes really good
but why is it red I mean I make these
lentil burgers and I know why it's red
because it has beets in there
do they just put in some [ __ ] up dye
in there it's just something I've
learned in life you cannot have your
cake and eat it and I'm eating this
thing it tastes like a burger it's not a
burger and I feel great afterwards and
I'm not fat okay that's not how this
world works all right to get something
you got to give something up okay that's
something
that's why they're always writing these
articles to women l king care women
really have it all no neither can med
you can't have it all you get something
you give something up okay your hands
are full you want something else you got
to drop something to get something else
that's how it works
you [ __ ] lunatics all right
says the guy talking to himself
screaming and yelling working himself
and do a leather alright how is an
impossible burger red showing the Hema
is the molecule that gives blood it's
red color and helps carry oxygen to
procure to produce the Hemi protein heme
a heme II protein from non-animal
sources impossible foods selected the
leg Hema globin molecule found naturally
in the roots of soy plants really okay
impossible burger how does it taste is
it safe now you don't even know where is
this coming from this is coming from the
[ __ ] red meat lobby this plant-based
burger looks and tastes like real beef
but is there a catch here on CNET
traditional veggie burgers they always
have to have three [ __ ] paragraphs of
[ __ ] yeah for the longest time we've
been eating burgers it all started on
the [ __ ] Freedom Trail alright in
fact veg'table uh despite the fact that
this lab-grown burger is unsettling to
some it's gotten so popular baba
ba-ba-ba-ba what are the ingredients
what does the impossible burger taste
like where to find the impossible burger
how to cook the impossible girl how much
does it cost
oh here we go is the impossible burger
safe to eat this feels like a commercial
here you can safely eat an impossible
burger unless you're allergic to soy
coconut or sunflower the ingredients in
the impossible
are simply and free of toxic Wow now
where is this coming from is it coming
from me coming from the impossible
burger well there you go
all right I'll guess I'll keep [ __ ]
eating those things oh you know I'll be
you know every once in a while
every every generation you know what you
have to be you have to be a [ __ ] lab
rat for certain [ __ ] right
okay the generations that came before
smoke cigarettes and they got lung
cancer and everybody's like oh I guess
we shouldn't do that right generations
before us did hope heroin and cocaine
and we were all like uh you know you do
it in moderation it's a tough one to
walk away from what else this J this
generation now these young kids these
[ __ ] young kids what are they going
to they're they're they're the guinea
pigs for vaping now look at a popcorn
lung these things are blowing up in
their faces well who knows I actually
think the cigarette companies unless
they make money off the vaping I would
think that they're out there trying to
do some [ __ ] I always take it back to
the Suzuki Samurai okay it ate into the
the American the AMC well who used to
make the Jeep it was an American motors
before Chrysler bought it I don't
[ __ ] remember but all I know was the
Jeep was the Jeep and there was nothing
else like it then all of a sudden the
Suzuki Samurai came along and every
psycho and all it was cheaper and it
undercut the Jeep and it really cut into
their sales and all of a sudden out of
nowhere there was all these [ __ ]
rumors about these [ __ ] things they
were tipping over and people will fall
and and die in and their faces were
getting [ __ ] ripped off like you know
like some grindhouse Tarantino [ __ ] was
happening in these [ __ ] things and
then years later it came out that
Chrysler who owned Jeep at the time just
kind of put those rumors out there like
oh my god did you hear about the Suzuki
Samurai she is such a [ __ ]
and and everybody's just like well [ __ ]
that homewrecker and then that was it
and it completely [ __ ] it over you
know I think the Suzuki Samurai came out
of Japan and generally speaking
a polite culture you know so they didn't
fight fire with fire they could have
came right back and said hey you know I
heard if you drive a jeep it means
you're a fat [ __ ] you got a little
dick you know it's just we heard try to
balance out the sales they didn't do it
um Oh anyway so anyway I've been out
here for about I've been living out here
in Los Angeles for 12 years I [ __ ]
love it out here and it really fits my I
don't know just my sense of who I think
I am it really fits like you know my
fantasies and and and my phone enos and
my you know even though I don't think
Botox was around then I sensed it was
coming and I thought that this was gonna
be the Ground Zero so I I liked being
out here
so anyways last night you know Oh Billy
[ __ ] freckles I had a big Hollywood
night last night I went to a premiere I
went to a movie premiere last night
everybody that's right you know I didn't
walk the red carpet because I want this
movie to make money I went it's [ __ ]
around here I went to the Hollywood
premiere of the new Adam Sandler movie
uncut gems you're out of your [ __ ]
mind if you don't go see this one I
think my stomach finally just unknotted
after watching that one it is [ __ ]
two hours I don't know how many I didn't
time it okay I was just eyes glued to
the screen
it was just [ __ ] relentless because
is crazy is Adam Sandler's character is
Howard you're rooting for the guy and
he's just making a lot of crazy
decisions I'm not gonna ruin everything
but I think the cast was incredible Adam
Sandler crushes it it's the best thing
I've ever seen him do Eric Bogosian was
amazing Julia Fox Kevin Garnett [ __ ]
killed it look heath Stanfield from
Atlanta killed it and I hope I say her
name is it Idina idina menzel
was amazing as Adam Sandler's
life man was that out that it was it's a
[ __ ] ride put it that way and I'm so
psyched
my buddy hooked me up I always his plus
one and you know the second I saw the
trailer I don't know if you guys if you
guys saw the trailer second I saw the
trailers like I'm [ __ ] seeing that
movie the first day so yeah it was
[ __ ] amazing and when it comes out on
Christmas Day I'm gonna take my wife
because she was breaking my freckle
balls that I didn't bring her she's like
I'm so jealous that you're [ __ ] going
to that and I was like I didn't say that
I was like I'm sorry do you want to go
in place of me I got to do that the next
time she's going out with one of her
friends I'm so jealous you're gonna go
to that [ __ ] cake fountain restaurant
that's one thing I've learned about the
ladies the ladies love a fountain they
don't give a [ __ ] what's coming out of
it water cheese chocolate anything
cascading you know but despite that will
they let you finish and that is what I
can't believe I just said that that is
one of life's big paradoxes anyways
speaking of ladies congratulations to
the Golden Globes you know sticking to
their guns not nominating any female
directors you know in this day and age
of just trying to please everybody I
really got a tip my cap to the Golden
Globes for keeping their standards where
they've always been and rather than
listening to all these people whining
this there's standing their ground and
you know this is their deal you want a
Golden Globe ladies you got it all this
[ __ ] bean-counting [ __ ] oh yeah where
there's not enough Sri Lanka's who want
out now
hey ladies why don't you suck it up
and make something so goddamn good the
golden globes cannot ignore you now they
don't want to do that do they huh I'm
just [ __ ] right I have no idea I just
saw a bunch of people up in arms about
that it will never cease to amaze me
that people adults full-grown adults
over the age of 30 brain is totally
developed want to win a trophy [ __ ]
eight years old first of all one of the
greatest things in the [ __ ] world is
not to be nominated because when you're
not nominated that means you don't have
to go to the [ __ ] show you know if
you really just sat down here thought it
through even if you get nominated the
[ __ ] odds are against you that you're
gonna win and then what you had to go I
had to go on some stupid [ __ ] diet
right yeah [ __ ] yakking behind your
goddamn house you know you [ __ ]
nannies got to pull you out of your
infinity pool as you're doing laps
because she's so [ __ ] undernourished
right then your stylist comes over you
know she's trying to put something on
your bony figure and all that [ __ ] and
then you're gonna sit there right before
you go there you're gonna shove an
impossible burger right you're probably
going to have it liquefied and then shot
up your ass by your [ __ ] celebrity
chef personal chef you know and then you
go to the red carpet oh my god Mandy
Mansfield what are you wearing what was
it like to work with so-and-so and then
you go in there and then you got to
watch the comedian come out there was
Lilly got a boo-boo what's [ __ ] up
with Trump Baba do-right there's [ __ ]
four hours of your life and then what
are you gettin you gotta sit there
waiting for your [ __ ] category
watching a bunch of people going on
stage all these ladies wearing $10,000
dresses they got their own TV show
they won the [ __ ] statue and then
they go up there and they're still
crying and whining about their lives
you're just [ __ ] sitting there okay
as your organs are starting to shut down
and you're literally getting to the
[ __ ] point of like oh my god I hope I
don't win this [ __ ] thing because I
don't even think I can make it from my
table up to that [ __ ] podium without
face planning on the [ __ ] stairs
I'm so [ __ ] undernourished right this
is what you campaign in for ladies okay
let me give you another scenario let me
give you my career all right so you like
to tell jokes huh giggling like a bunch
of schoolgirls I got a joke for you
ten guys sitting around a bullpen where
I'm how the [ __ ] they ever got there
what do we do
or should we a dog I'll give you a story
all right [ __ ] playing funny bones
and improv the prey improv right sitting
in [ __ ] 9 hours of traffic for a
[ __ ] place that's literally [ __ ]
if you got on a [ __ ] scooter you
could have got there in nine minutes
you know [ __ ] playing a cop playing a
fireman you know that playing another
cop than playing another fireman than a
farmer and then a [ __ ] cop
eight lines in this movie six lines in
that movie all
that you probably look at me and you
like wow I feel bad for that guy but
guess what guess what I'm doing on the
night of the Golden Globes I'm at home
I'm eating a giant [ __ ] burger I got
a handful of Hershey kisses I'm shoving
them down my [ __ ] throat I'm watching
SportsCenter nobody's asking me what I'm
wearing I got a beautiful wife that
loves me and I got a great kid gives a
[ __ ] about the Golden Globes oh those
are those the go Globes that are golden
no boy I should shut up I should shut up
cuz someday you know what something you
know what
someday f is for family is gonna get
nominated for a Golden Globe category
and the winner is the Sri Lankans
soliloquies with the Golden Globes but
by dabbu anyway that level never cease
to [ __ ] amaze me you know or why
don't why don't ladies why don't you
guys start your own awards show right
here's the deal like you don't know you
do you understand the power you have
women what is an awards show without a
bunch of hot [ __ ] pieces of ass
walking around now if none of you ladies
go to that and then you start the hot
piece of ass golden globes
alright you [ __ ] do that
and then then what who's gonna want to
go to Golden Globes there's no [ __ ]
hot chicks there you go to that thing I
don't know
haven't you learned anything watching
sports leagues the [ __ ] NFL wouldn't
let people in so a bunch of guys got
together said [ __ ] it we'll make our own
league the AFL and it's eight nine years
later right Broadway Joe Goes Down and
wins the only one that jets ever [ __ ]
150 [ __ ] years ago you know we'll
walk on the moon again before the Jets
win the [ __ ] super boy I hate to say
it I actually don't hate to say I
actually kind of enjoyed saying that
there we go there's some truth alright
once you start start a competing Golden
Globes why don't you do that
stop trying to join amazing [ __ ] that
men created what are you afraid of
ladies can't you go out and start
something on your own by the way why
don't women support the WNBA I don't
[ __ ] understand it should have been
in there from day one and gone right to
the top and just become the female Kurt
Goudy why why didn't you do that now you
did rather go to the [ __ ] NFL and
stand there freezing your [ __ ] tits
off on the goddamn sideline you know
going Tom Brady I think he got his thumb
Chee I'm sure I'm ready
how does your thumb feel there's a third
fine right click you could be inside I
don't know you know what sometimes I
start talking and I don't know where my
brain goes and my mouth keeps moving how
long was that
I just [ __ ] talk for a while I feel
like I don't know that I said anything
but I do know this if you're still
listening that means you listen to all
of it and what does that say about you
I always blame the victim one of my
favorite things to do in the world is
punch down you know I just love watching
other adults go ah all right doll you
know when I talk about Dollar Shave Club
I can't stress enough the quality of
their products according to this copy
that was written for me that is saying
things that I never see why don't you
just ask me what I think about to all
the shape club I think it's [ __ ]
great okay and of all of their products
I'll tell you the greatest one ever is
the one white shark Charlie one white
Charlie's the greatest [ __ ] thing
ever it's the poor man's bidet okay I'm
not gonna go into detail I think I've
painted enough of a picture and I'm
gonna continue with this copy you know
they spent years developing crafting
refining everything that's what they did
they say they [ __ ] Nick they just
kept working on their formula for this
shaving cream just shaving one lab rat
after another until they want they found
a lab rat that was just so shaped who
shaped so smoothly that even when they
set it down all the ladies in the room
would like oh my god I have to snuggle
with it they have everything I to look
and feel and smell my best you name it
they have it and I use it is that right
I used the one wipe Charlies I've been
it I've been a dollar shave club member
for years please talk about your
experience using the executive razor
never used it the shaved butter never
used it the prep scrub I don't know if I
use that where's the one wipe charlie
that's what I used anyways the a this
[ __ ] [ __ ] works they have shaving
cream they have shaved they got the prep
scrub you put it on beforehand Dollar
Shave Club has you covered from head to
toe they have everything you need to
shower shave style your hair I don't
have any hair I got a beard brush your
teeth and yes even wipe your butt there
my wheelhouse right there you know I
believe outcasts wrote a song about
[ __ ] one wipe Charlies so hey Dollar
Shave Club can keep you automatically
stocked up on the products you use you
get what you want whenever you need it
whether that's once a month or a few
times a year I never have to waste time
at a store wondering if what I'm getting
is any good as a Dollar Shave Club
member I know evidently what I'm getting
is the highest quality I'll tell you
right now I just got all of this [ __ ] I
gave to andrew thumbless that's all I do
I have enough [ __ ] toiletries from
being on the road for 20 [ __ ] I still
have shampoo from a super 8 off of rural
road 9 in [ __ ] Arkansas all right I
want to hear it alright ai-ai-ai-aight
if you saw my the amount of [ __ ]
hotels shampoos and [ __ ] horseshit
that I have in my bathroom you would
think that I was one of those guys that
were preparing for doomsday alright now
here's the thing none of you guys are
traveling comedians I'm imagining so you
don't have the war chest of shampoos and
soaps and lotions that I have so you
need this Dollar Shave Club and right
now you can put the quality of Dollar
Shave Club products to the test their
ultimate shaver starter set has
basically everything you need for an
amazing shave the executive razor shave
butter prep scrub and post shave do the
best part is you can try it for just 5
bucks
and that and after that sorry though the
restock box ships regular sized products
at the regular prices get your ultimate
set for just $5 at Dollar for 5 bucks at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's jolly
shave club dot-com / / oh look who's
back Oh max whether you're an athlete a
weekend warrior or someone who deals
with constant joint pain back pain
muscle soreness or maybe you maybe maybe
you married the
wrong person right you can take this Oh
max and just roll it around the inside
of your ears and everything they're
gonna say is gonna be nice and soothing
or arthritis find a natural remedy that
instantly works might seem non-existent
what finding a natural remedy that
most over-the-counter pain relievers
such as icy hot and bengay only focus on
one basic cooling effect such as menthol
which temporarily takes your mind off
the pain until that pain returns in an
hour so this is really a metaphor for a
bad relationship all right you want to
meet the love of your life
get Oh max waiting for you if you're
looking to get rid of nagging muscle or
joint pain immediately while providing
long lasting recovery then you need to
try the natural breakthrough pain relief
solution cryofreeze CBD developed by Oh
max health health period sorry this
non-prescription triple-action pain
relief roll-on is specially formulated
to block pain receptors reduce
inflammation this is where it goes the
extra mile
anybody can block a pain receptor Christ
you could do that with a bottle of
[ __ ] Johnnie Walker red all right but
can Johnnie Walker red reduce
inflammation no alcohol from what I'm
told actually increases it it reduces
inflammation and improve muscle and
joint flexibility the best part is this
is 100% natural CBD CBD powered remedy
works its magic within 10 minutes of
application and relief lasts up to 8
hours much longer than over-the-counter
products it's super easy to throw in
your gym bag and take I'll just picture
some guys rolling it on his balls and
taking up oh my god my balls are soaked
menthol fresh on the go for emergency
pain relief simply roll it over wherever
it hurts and ice out the pain with the
arctic blast the real secret behind
cryofreeze pain relief roll-on is its
- leading-edge pain relief ingredients
CBD known for its unique therapeutic
effect on cellular pain receptors and
menthol for its soothing sensation of
pain cryofreeze is advanced I have some
of this [ __ ] I want to go put some on my
shoulder right now I did a little rehab
on it yesterday the treatment exposes
the body to a cold temperature in order
to numb and reduce pain and inflammation
how many [ __ ] times can they say the
same thing ok remember go - Oh max
health calm oh ma ex health calm today
and enter the code burr to take
advantage of this incredible savings om
ax health calm and enter the code bird
to get 20% off cryofreeze and site-wide
if you're still not so go read all the
5-star reviews they have coming from my
podcast and others at all max health
calm alright lastly but not leastly i'm
progressive when it comes to [ __ ]
reading ad [ __ ] right simply safe I want
to remind my listeners time is running
out on simply safes huge holiday offer
it's their biggest sale of the year hey
if you're looking to fully protect your
home with award-winning 24/7 home
security now is the time to do it
burglary spike during the holiday season
aha Santa's not real but the Grinch is
with families traveling and leaving
empty homes and expensive gifts behind
simply safes holidays sale couldn't come
at a better time
simply safe has everything you need to
protect your home and family how the
[ __ ] do you rob presents out from
underneath the tree how do you find the
humor in that maybe you just go down the
chimney and you do the whole [ __ ]
thing you're a man warden mr. Brij
there's a smart lock and video doorbell
perot to defend that's what you do when
you're counting it you listen to the
who's from Whoville singing that song
[Music]
simply safe has everything you need to
protect your home and family there's a
smartlock in video doorbell Pro to
defend your front door an army of
sensors and cameras that guards every
window door and room in your home if
there's a break-in they can give real
time video confirmation to the police as
it happens so police responds up to 3.5
times faster this has to be terrifying
for people that actually steal Christmas
gifts for a living no surprise simply
fit safe has 1c net and PC Magazine
Editors Choice Awards simply safe made a
holiday offer with our my listeners in
mind but it ends December 31st they
rarely do deals this big so now's your
chance visit simply safecom / / to find
out just how much you'll save and
remember this sale ends December 31st go
to simply safe dot-com / BER alright
that's the power of the pot politics
that's the podcast my boss did Bruins
lost to the Ottawa Senators last night
they playing Tampa Bay tonight and who
else do they got Boston Celtics they
lost to the Pacers last night and who do
they got tonight I think they both have
like back-to-back games which is [ __ ]
annoying you know don't they have any
consideration for people that like both
sports I don't think they do
they got Philly tonight
all right so guess what the [ __ ] I'll be
doing at 5 o'clock flip-flopping back
and forth between the two all right
oh [ __ ] what's-his-face the free agent
that we had the guy from Atlanta I can't
remember his for I can't remember it's
like they can Robert Horry the greatest
free agent of all [ __ ] time the [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] is out what the [ __ ] was
his name I I love the guy he was with
the Celtics he did a great [ __ ] job
Philadelphia Sixers roster roster so
[ __ ] his name Al Horford there you go
we get to play Al Horford what a great
pickup by the six or so what if they're
having a good season I don't know I
don't have the [ __ ] time all right
that's it everybody enjoy your weekend
you [ __ ] please
December 25th go see uncut gems Adam
Sandler's best movie and I've seen them
all all right I'd never lie to you go
check it out okay I guarantee you're
gonna love it
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend
go Bruins go Celtics go Pat's hey what's
going on how are you it's bill burns the
Monday morning podcast from Monday
December 12 2011 I am sweaty roast and
bacon boy do you like a sauna I'm
[ __ ] sick you like my voice droid
I got [ __ ] sick this week too much
[ __ ] traveling around too much flying
all over the place doing all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I don't know what I
did I [ __ ] woke up shook too many
hands scratch my nose in here I said
hang on one second everybody yeah all
right
that's [ __ ] gross you know having a
beard is awesome until you have a cold
I'm gonna leave it at that
jesus [ __ ] christ
you know what's funny is I I am I'm like
a key that's sort of a key sick you know
it's just [ __ ] and I haven't even
started my goddamn Christmas shopping
which is something I don't even know why
I have to [ __ ] do it you know
Christmas is the most [ __ ] up holiday
on the face of the earth I don't get
what is it you know can we make up our
minds is it Jesus birthday or is it the
[ __ ] the fat guy coming down the
chimney you know it's both
you know subject I gotta go with Jesus
on Christmas that's who I gotta go with
I like Jesus on Christmas
I like Jesus I like him at Christmastime
I like Jesus because he's got the water
and wine
I like Jesus you know why cuz I don't
have to buy any [ __ ] gifts for that
sob and he is it SOP right oh wait he
knew who's his father was his father who
art in heaven it's his father who is in
heaven
you know not trying to nitpick our
Father who isn't evident big up to he he
[ __ ] kidding me
man you [ __ ] kid you know how [ __ ]
weird it is to be this sick living in a
dancer I want to thank everybody who
came out to the Bray improv this weekend
I had an awesome time out there I
apologize if I was a little bit grumpy
you know I just have [ __ ] traffic
always gets me going out there it always
gets me you know it just kills me that
you know like I loved living in Los
Angeles until I get on those goddamn
highways and then I feel unbelievably
claustrophobic because I just feel like
there is no [ __ ] way out and some
[ __ ] went down where do I go there's no
way there's nowhere to go you know
I'll tell where the apocalypse comes I'm
just gonna get my Jam jams I'm gonna put
on a robe you know whenever whatever
[ __ ] angry persons gonna come down
from heaven cuz he's mad at me cuz I
rubbed one out to the Mary chick down
the block you know you think you're
gonna [ __ ] scare me
alright you will but you think I'm gonna
[ __ ] dress like I'm scared you think
I'm gonna get on those [ __ ] highways
and do some futile drive to where Vegas
the [ __ ] am I gonna go I'm gonna sit
here my [ __ ] Jam jams it's like
saying that they [ __ ] Jam jams that
I'm gonna drink some tea like I'm doing
right now
oh hello demon from another world do I
not have enough [ __ ] saintly frequent
flyer miles to get upgraded into heaven
you know I don't know what you're so
[ __ ] excited about you're goin down
to hell with me you [ __ ]
you know why don't we join forces and
tack those up in first class what do you
say alright so anyways are you know
something what's so [ __ ] up about the
population problem in this world is we
could just [ __ ] deal with it right
now in an easy way rather then go in the
hard route you know just right now let
everybody have one kid so you got that
thing that half looks like you half
looks like your wife and gonna be like
I've continued the bloodline alright
then you want more kids just go out and
adopt there's plenty of [ __ ] kids
around the world sitting in a [ __ ]
mud hole trying to dig out a goddamn
diamond so you can [ __ ] pay 9 zillion
dollars for it and give it to you
[ __ ] broad on Christmas you know why
don't you adopt one of those diamond
digging sons of [ __ ] teaching the
language little [ __ ] we'll go on the
back yard I'll make you a fortune
you know just digging it up little
adopted kid dig it up you know why don't
we do that and then you just let some
old people die and you let people fall
off [ __ ] ladders and all that type
[ __ ] the population would gradually go
drought down no everyone's just gonna
keep [ __ ] you know they haven't
brand-new kids that's what they want
they want brand-new kids nobody wants
nobody wants to [ __ ] use what no one
wants to take a chance on a barn find
you know some little kid you know with
the original motor living up in the loft
of a barn for the last 20 years you know
matching numbers you know what that then
you teach them how to be a good kid
little body off restoration a little
rotisserie right does anybody else watch
the speech channel don't you love that
[ __ ] channel and [ __ ] love that
channel I love watching them taking cars
that I like and they redo them I don't
like the custom [ __ ]
you know I don't like what the outside
looks like an old car and then the
inside you know looks like a [ __ ]
rappers foyer you know all leather and
all everything's oh I don't like it like
that I like it like that
everything's reminded me of a song today
I like when they just you know I'm big
on the [ __ ] interior which is why I
never bought the Dodge Challenger you
know the outside of that car is [ __ ]
it's beautiful I love it you know I see
it my heart starts racing what if my
hands goes into one of my pockets I get
I get arrested for lewd behavior with an
inanimate object I love it but I get in
the [ __ ] thing and I might as well be
sitting in a Chrysler 300 I don't see
what what the [ __ ] deal is what's the
deal was going on so today it looked
like [ __ ] hang on you know it's the
worst when I get sick when I bite into a
york peppermint pattie when I get sick
everybody now I will just throw that
over there when I get sick what I do is
I just act like I'm not sick and I just
continued to do the [ __ ] that I'm that I
normally do you know I don't run around
but you know yesterday I'm [ __ ] sick
and Nia starts telling me that I got out
of there you know you got to stay in bed
the whole day and drink liquids it's
like yeah okay I'm not doing that I have
a cold I don't have cancer all right
[ __ ] you know what I mean
I can drink liquid laying on the couch
watching football she got so [ __ ] mad
at me that's all my buddies calling me
on football Sunday you know cuz we
gamble we throw the money around just
with each other you know so there's a
lot of texting there's a lot of [ __ ]
talking and that type of stuff and I got
to get on the phone after a while and
defend myself if one of my picks isn't
coming through Tampa Bay Buccaneers the
[ __ ] happened in those [ __ ]
yesterday huh I thought that was a win
14 nothing I was all set I don't even
watch the game went in the kitchen I'm
making an English muffin and I come back
it's like [ __ ] 72 14 so anyways
anyways uh yeah my friends just kept
calling me and I kept picking up the
phone and I was talking [ __ ] and she
just kept glaring at me you know it
really made me mad you know it's like
what the [ __ ] let me be sick how I want
to be sick you mad at me cuz I'm sick no
mad at you because you're an idiot
you're not doing the things you need to
do to get better I am doing the [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] sitting on laying on the [ __ ]
couch you know what does it difference
between laying on the [ __ ] couch
watching television as opposed to laying
on the [ __ ] bed room with nothing
staring at the goddamn wall you know I'm
gonna start moaning when I'm in there
that's why [ __ ] people moan when
they're you know you don't have a
[ __ ] TV you start moaning no all
right you're miserable you get that
[ __ ] TV going you forget you have a
cold especially with all these [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] calls this year I swear to God I
don't even recognize the NFL anymore you
know why is it illegal to cover a
[ __ ] wide receiver why are five guys
gonna break Dan Marino's yardage for the
year record you know it's such [ __ ]
[ __ ] I had the
giant yesterday getting four - right
Eli Manning is the [ __ ] man all right
you know what he's like he's like Serena
and [ __ ] Peyton Manning is like Venus
Venus came out early right and
everybody's like oh oh [ __ ] look at
Venus Venus you're gonna win everything
right then we'll cap and all of a sudden
Sarina came out of [ __ ] nowhere BAM
she starts [ __ ] winning Eli Manning
has way more come from behind wins then
Peyton Manning does I'm telling you he
does and I would rather have the ball in
his hands than Peyton's you know go
ahead and argue go ahead and roll your
eyes there stat boy come at me with all
your fantasy football stats from games 1
through 16 both of them had the ball in
their hands with only a minute left in
the Superbowl one drove down to victory
to glory
to legendary status the other threw a
pick 6 to lose the [ __ ] Super Bowl
how many times this year how many
[ __ ] times does Eli Manning have to
win a game on the last Drive to get some
goddamn respect in this [ __ ] league
that guy is a beast he's a [ __ ] beast
yeah he doesn't throw as many [ __ ]
yards sheriff he's not as funny in the
commercials but if you want wins that's
your man that is your [ __ ] man I am
totally sold on that [ __ ]
right as opposed to Tony Romo that's why
you know that's why I picked the giant
yesterday it's like you know what NFC
East it's gotta be a closed [ __ ] game
it's gonna come down to the wire the
ball is gonna be an eel eyes hand and
Tony Romo's hand you know but because
the way they cover [ __ ] receivers
they're the goddamn game one and they
give up 50 yards on to [ __ ] place I'm
sick of it that stupid [ __ ] prevent
defense the fact that you can't touch
the [ __ ] receivers they're making
every quarterback out there look like
they're John Elway look like
[ __ ] Joe Montana and these [ __ ]
guys there's a lot of padded stats going
on out there that's all I'm saying I'm
sick of these [ __ ] wide receivers
getting treated like these goddamn diva
[ __ ] on vh1 all right I don't think
that we should go back to the Jack Tatum
era where he would just sucker punch
guys they wouldn't even play the [ __ ]
ball you ever watch that guy's
highlights it's [ __ ] ridiculous
quarterbacks I mean the [ __ ] wide
receivers got his head turned around
looking at the ball and he would just
clock him in the head when they weren't
looking kind of like that douche who
punched that big white boy
there on the on the college basketball
court total [ __ ] sucker punch but
whose fault was that I say it's the big
white boys the first thing you got to
understand is when you're involved in
one of the hoes West Side Story beat it
video deals in real life when [ __ ] 10
psychos meet with 10 other psychos the
punch is never coming from whoever
you're looking at in the [ __ ] history
of mobs me I bet if you went back to the
Revolutionary War that poor black dude
the first one to get shot do you think
if he was looking at the person who shot
him of course he wasn't it's probably
some British guy the other side hey over
here mate you you with the you with the
tan over here somebody else shot him in
the [ __ ] gut that's how it works
you know so in the words of
what's-his-face from the old Tampa Bay
Warren Sapp and the words of Warren Sapp
keep your head on a swivel
let's I'm when he knocked that dude out
he knocked that [ __ ] guy you know
total [ __ ] cheap shot he just kept
going keep your head on a swivel keep
your head on a swivel he was right not
saying what he did wasn't a piece of
[ __ ] move but you know wasn't illegal
what the [ __ ] am I talking about I don't
know I can't even laid out I'm so
[ __ ] congested that's another thing
too and then everybody comes up to you
starts giving you pills when you're sick
you know you're walking around like Jim
Morrison in 1968 people handing you acid
and say man try this it's gonna work
right [ __ ] alka-seltzer cold medicine
I don't know I just know it's all
kicking the [ __ ] out of my liver you
ever look at a color of dayquil how in
God's name is that medicine like how the
[ __ ] is that good for you I forget what
you live liver does but it's basic it's
basically responsible your liver is like
that tent city in Scarface
you know just underneath the overpass
all these [ __ ] scumbags you know now
would you or you take those [ __ ]
pills that's where it goes that's who
has to process it you know I want my
[ __ ] children rights you know that's
your liver a little picture Jimmy Carter
right over your over its shoulder I just
try to tough it up that's what I do I go
old school
I get Kleenex I drink a little bit of
tea and I try to stay away from all that
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] unless I have shows
if I have shows I drug myself up like
Elvis like Elvis in 1976 I'll need a man
come on I ain't [ __ ] in three days give
me some more do you know when they did
the autopsy on him a giant capsule came
out of his ass do you realize that still
intact it's unreal
I don't know what I'm talking about this
week everybody this week actually coming
up coming up this week people the
redheaded [ __ ] tour just continues I
am going to Tempe Arizona you know and
I'm playing at The Improv out there
Friday and Saturday and I'm hanging
around because Arizona who I lost money
on is what the [ __ ] who they played they
playing the Browns why is everything a
song to me this week that was I get
around from the beach voice you like
that little song parodies I'm going
super hack with you guys hang on a
second while I drink some organic throat
coat tea hellgate is that drinks out I
always hate that that's one of the few
things in my writer it's water and
organic throat code tea this stuff is
the [ __ ] but there's certain things that
are just you should just have a gay guy
step in right as you go to order it you
know like in the most flamboyant least
stereotypical gay guy ever
you'd be like yes bill can we get
anything for the show yeah I just need
some water and some and then some guy
steps in gay guy organic throat Cote
right that's like when I used to live in
New York and I used to get that [ __ ]
tasty treat down the street
coconut dream bar is what it was called
and I just couldn't get myself to say it
I'd be like let me get one of those
coconut things and the person always be
like you mean the coconut dream bar yes
I do
that's exactly what I mean would you
like us to heat it up and shove it in
your ass now I'll take it at room
temperature thank you all right here we
go let's uh let's get going here all
right we're bringing this one back
douche bag of the week this guy said
I've been a longtime listener I've been
to your last few stand-up shows in
Seattle all right so right there
once again establishing credibility okay
he's a fan both at work and I support
you you know when you come out so
all right off the bat he's setting this
thing up like I have something that I
can take away from you you know I could
take my $8 off the table there
freckle-faced anyways he says can you do
us all a favor us now he's speaking for
the group and cancel the dilemmas
segment these are both not funny and
really stupid my dilemma for you would
you rather listen to Bill burrs dilemma
dilemmas or realize you have lost your
comedic talent because you allowed
idiots to take over your show that's
kind of a weird question would you
rather listen to Bill burrs dilemma or
realize you've lost your comedic talents
dude first of all you're the warrior
this is why your douche bag of the week
not because you don't like dilemmas it's
because you did that classic thing that
people do when they write a complaint
letter is you act as though you just
you're sitting in a room with 800 other
[ __ ] people and they're all going hey
douchebag write it for us cuz we don't
know how to this is the only complaint I
got about dilemmas alright so I don't
know who the [ __ ] you're speaking for
are you trapped in a mine shaft with
some [ __ ] wireless internet is that
what you're doing go [ __ ] yourself buddy
in an honor of you it's time for
dilemmas dilemmas alright I haven't even
read these [ __ ] yet but you know
that's what makes this segment so
annoying to this guy so I'm gonna try to
be extra unfunny during these hang on a
second let me blow my nose well maybe I
should blow my nose during the middle of
it to make it even more annoying cuz God
what would I do without this douchebag
listening to my podcast hey [ __ ] do
you realize how many podcasts are out
there why don't you go listen to those
wants to be so [ __ ] unhappy with this
one
alright and I don't need you coming to
my shows alright you [ __ ]
you and your 800 invisible friends can
go [ __ ] yourself what do think about
that huh hang on a second
and another thing alright we're up to
three Kleenexes by the way okay alright
dilemmas for the week go to the bathroom
like a cat number one and number two in
a dresser drawer sized cat box
and have a butler empty it every day or
go to the bathroom like a dog outside in
the bushes and have a butler follow you
around to pick it up and tell you that
you're a good boy oh that's no fights no
fight at that second one I do it outside
its squat right down in the [ __ ]
bushes much [ __ ] inside my house that's
why I hate cats aside from the fact that
they act like stuck-up [ __ ] at a club
you know who've never done composts
anything other than looking good in life
you know and they only come around when
they [ __ ] need something
the only other reason why I don't like
cats and say [ __ ] in the [ __ ] house
then I gotta pick it up I don't like
that they're not happy when I come home
it's just no there's no give-and-take
you know it is when you have a cat
you're basically Robert De Niro's
character and Casino that's what you are
you know and your cat is Sharon Stone
she's [ __ ] she's just there for the
amenities you [ __ ] [ __ ] go OD in a
goddamn Red Roof Inn all right so yeah I
would definitely outside who doesn't
like being told they're a good boy I get
praise what was last time anybody out
there got praise after they took a dump
would that be awesome you know I don't
know all right let's plow ahead was that
unfunny sir did you not like that one
was that not up to your comedy standards
did you feel the rest of this podcast
was funnier than that when I blew my
nose before I went off on Jesus oh all
right let's just blow my head here
number two would you rather marry a
stripper or have your daughter become
one I'd rather marry one I'd rather
marry one you know if my daughter
becomes one that's just complete failure
as a parent and in fact that's what I
think all those videos should be called
that you see you know when you see on
YouTube when you got those girls doing
those booty dances you know what the
goddamn shorts up their ass like it's
always like someone's so booty dancing
what it should be
is so-and-so complete failure that's a
pair well results of a complete failure
as a parent absolutely I would rather
that's not fair to the kid I would marry
a stripper and you know I would just I
would just have fun with the stripper I
would just do whatever I could you know
[ __ ] her as she had one leg pointed west
and one leg pointed East you know or
north and south if she's standing up
drinking coffee you know doing like one
of those little ballet moves I just
bagger like that and then ya don't have
a kid and be like listen this is the
secret in life sweetheart don't do
anything that your mother didn't would
she just become a stripper is that like
a reality show that they haven't come up
with yet daughters of strippers like
what's-her-face
I think Kurt Cobain's daughter it's
gonna be all right
cuz her mother is such a [ __ ] that it
thinks I probably just jinxed her I
probably just jinxed her all right
number three choose between attacked by
a bear or a lion on land in between
attacked by a shark or crocodile in the
water no [ __ ] contest dude I would
take a barren bear or a lion that's a
quick death that's a quick one that bear
comes up with that Bionic bitch-slap
that's it you [ __ ] break [ __ ] neck
you ever see a lion kill something
that's it it's over like and it that's
going after like major prey and it just
crushes your [ __ ] windpipe you're out
in two seconds did you ever yo the
footage of what's-his-face like the gay
lion tamer out there the one who looked
like what's-his-face from night at the
Roxbury the job Jesus Christ this
[ __ ] cold medicine what the [ __ ] is a
guy's name there come on what was what's
the name of that guy Chris Kattan that
one the gay Chris Kattan you ever see
one that [ __ ] that lion grabbed that
dude and it was over in two seconds he
just went limp I take that in a second
as opposed to a [ __ ] shark you
sitting out there shark comes out first
thing it does is it bite
do you like to see if you're edible
right just takes a nice chunk out no
like he's doing some sort of wide
testing with your [ __ ] thigh meat you
know what else kills me is the fact you
can't [ __ ] see it you know your heads
above the water and all the evil is just
below it you're sitting there you know
and I think that you had still you got
that caveman DNA that would that would
just be going off that there was
something in the area despite the fact
that you couldn't see it you'd be trying
to lift your [ __ ] legs up I I think I
think the real dilemma here is is
between shark or crocodile and I I would
have to go I would have to go shark I
just feel like there it's a cleaner
death you know I got those Ginsu knife
teeth they just come in like a tiger
shark it's just [ __ ] over you know
just a perfect [ __ ] killing machine
as they said in Jaws
but like alligators and crocodiles those
[ __ ] things those are like those guys
who aren't talent talented enough to be
in the NFL in the NHL so they just go
out there and they try to blow out guy's
knees you know alligators and crocodiles
like the bill Romanowski
of [ __ ] predators you know just that
thing where they grab onto you you know
what I like about a shark it which you
could just bite your leg off look
[ __ ] alligator they always seem to
grab it and then they go into that role
and they just so slowly twist it off you
know like you're some cooked chicken and
they're trying to take the leg it's just
getting [ __ ] morbid that's what I
would choose all right what else we got
here have a beautiful lay who stinks
smelly breath smelly ass [ __ ] pits hair
the works all stinking or an ugly fat
[ __ ] who smells great I go with the
ugly fat girl smells great absolutely
because I could I could love her well
the other one who just smelled like [ __ ]
but was beautiful it was probably
carrying herself like a beautiful lady
would annoy me after a while it I'd
probably kill her you know why did you
kill her cuz her [ __ ] [ __ ] stunk and
she walked around like she was Giselle
am I being charged with anything cuz if
I am I want a lawyer
go [ __ ] yourselves well mr. burr you
really just already incriminating
yourself I don't care you know the
prison will not smell as bad as her ass
I was anything worse than [ __ ] cold
tea alright here we go
chip first linebacker built my friends
and I frequently get in an argument over
whether a world's a world's man
competitor or NFL lineman could handle a
chimp in a fight
I know chimps can rip faces off in a ten
times the strength of a normal man but a
normal man is a tub of [ __ ] I bet a
linebacker could rip some faces off -
what do you think
yeah no contest the chimp would [ __ ] the
dude up do chimps don't fight I was
gonna have a set fairly chimps don't
fight like people they're not gonna you
know you gotta come out come out and
touch gloves and they're gonna [ __ ] it
sorry he's got a great jab watch out for
it's right you know that [ __ ] thing
is just gonna jump on you let me tell
you that time that monkey stole my hotel
keys I was in Costa Rica the [ __ ] was I
down to Costa Rica way out in the bush
you know army ants took over my [ __ ]
little cabana and that type of [ __ ] so
they had this pet monkey there I was a
monkey I [ __ ] ate monkeys I never had
a problem with chimps but now that
they've ripped people's faces off and
then nuts and their feet off I have a
problem with them I like gorillas and I
like orangutan rang at ants I always
thought it was tang T ang butts
orangutan I like those ones they seem
like they've seen it all they got that
vibe they could just sit down and teach
you about life but those little monkey
[ __ ] I can't stand it right so
for some dumb reason cuz I'm white I
have to walk up to it hey there's a
[ __ ] wild animal
let me put myself in danger and I walk
up
this thing and it [ __ ] jumps on me
you know it's one of those you know
member that that that video I shocked
the monkey the little monkey in that
thing was one of those monkeys or in the
faces of death when they were [ __ ]
banging that monkey's head till it died
then they ate his brains remember that
one yeah I was one of those monkeys
right this [ __ ] thing jumped on me
and within half a second it turned
itself upside down was hanging by its
tail from my neck reached in my pockets
grabbed my keys and ran back up a
[ __ ] tree this all happened like
within like 1.8 seconds and my body
reactions like whoa wait what what huh
[ __ ] so if this thing actually wanted to
[ __ ] you up the things not gonna come
out [ __ ] bobbin and Weavin it's gonna
be running around the room jumping up
off of [ __ ] you gotta try to figure out
where it is and it's just gonna [ __ ]
land on your face now that's gonna be it
it's gonna tear your face off twist your
foot off and rip your balls off and no
linebacker stands a [ __ ] chance
unless you know what what if they had on
the equipment even then they tell your
fingers off this is the amazing thing
about how human being survived is
everything out there's as far as I can
tell is faster than us for the most part
it is stronger than us faster and
stronger but for the simple fact that we
were smarter we were able to do all the
horrific things that we've done with
this nature you know with this nature
with this planet you ever think about
that [ __ ] football players beat the [ __ ]
out of the Nerds all through grade
school in high school then what happens
from the real deal goes down the end of
the day those nerds become bankers and
those football players get enslaved and
there you sit in your house like a caged
animal let the [ __ ] zoo and where's
that banker you don't even know what the
[ __ ] he looks like all those Facebook
[ __ ] that goddamn Steve Jobs or the
most overrated human beings on the
[ __ ] planet they win in the end
intelligent wins oh you know what that
reminds me do you guys see Rolling Stone
this week they're like the hundred
greatest guitarists of all time you know
they got to do like [ __ ] like that like
every three weeks no because no
nobody buys magazines anymore so they
always have to do like those you know
top sexiest tambourine players of 1986
they do one of those countdowns because
it always causes arguments but they had
a an article in there on what do they
come basically extremely gifted kids and
now there's really no programs out there
for the extremely gifted there's like
one school in the country that actually
caters to them at like a grade school
level you know and and it's kind of been
viewed that skipping grades and all that
is bad for the kids socially and now
they're realizing it's the complete
opposites these kids get [ __ ]
depressed because they go to school and
everybody's so much [ __ ] dumber than
they are you know and their quest for
knowledge fills their heart the way you
know you like [ __ ] they were talking
about this one kid by the time he was
four years old he spoke like three
different languages he had gone through
the entire periodic table and was really
into rocks and minerals so he goes out
with all these regular [ __ ] kids who
were gonna basically end up working at a
Buffalo Wild Wings someday and they're
out there throwing rocks and stuff and
this kids trying to tell them about the
crystals that are in the rocks and how
they were formed and everybody was like
you're a stupid liar
no one is it they like throwing rocks I
was just thinking like he can't how he
can't even [ __ ] relate to anybody his
own age and they get depressed and they
don't want to be smart and after a while
they just go comatosed and if they stay
in the environment too long they can't
even hold down a menial job in life it's
[ __ ] unreal and the entire time I was
reading the article just fascinated and
laughing my ass off and imagining this
kid being that [ __ ] smart I mean it's
bad enough as a comedian to do a third
show Saturday night in front of a bunch
of goddamn drunks you know they mean the
gap in intelligence they're just
for the simple fact that I'm sober is
unbelievably annoying and it's full-on
[ __ ] torture for an hour and this kid
has to live it every day six hours at
school and the gap between him and those
kids I mean that [ __ ] kid couldn't
even have a conversation with me without
getting bored just sitting there these
[ __ ] kid was coming home he's going
they're treating us like puppies Christ
I could teach the [ __ ] class so I
definitely recommend reading it you know
what's funny is this kid his parents
just what they did was they just applied
him had him take that he applied for
college and he tested off the charts and
they accepted him and then they said oh
by the way he's only like he's like 11
now and they let him in and this is the
funny thing one of the schools he went
to was a rapaho Community College in
Colorado and I performed at that school
and if you guys listen to me tell
stories about some of the worst gigs I
ever had I always bring up a rapaho
Community College as a reference because
I did a nooner at that school in an area
with three three hallways met a neuter
is basically you're doing the show at
like 12 noon or 1 o'clock in the
afternoon it's a [ __ ] nightmare
all right kids have no ideas there's a
show most of the time the show is held
in like the cafeteria you know I'll tell
you I've really got to be honest with
you level of [ __ ] humiliation that
you have to go through to even get to
where the [ __ ] I'm at here is a goddamn
gauntlet a [ __ ] that's what it is
it's just one impossible humiliating
[ __ ] scenario after another and then
every once in a while there's like that
you know like when Columbus saw a branch
floating in the water so you knew he was
getting the land you'd have a couple of
good shows so anyways I'm [ __ ]
standing there three in this area with
three hallways meet they start the show
in between classes it's me and like six
kids sitting there and one of the people
is like the person who booked the
[ __ ] show and I'm 20 minutes into my
act standing next to this popcorn
machine just bombing
just bombing and all of a sudden this
[ __ ] Bell goes off or whatever the
[ __ ] happened and all the classes let
out and within two seconds it was like a
flash flood of like people all of a
sudden all the quarters were filled with
people and they're just walking by
looking at me with like this combination
of like confusion and pity and then they
just started [ __ ] heckling me and all
I could do was [ __ ] on the school for
putting me in that situation now this
remember the person booking the gig
everything that I would say she'd just
be good that's not true that isn't true
this is a great school and she was mad
at me in the end and I was so [ __ ]
furious at myself for taking the gig and
in her going like how did you think that
this was gonna [ __ ] work you know do
you ever watch stand-up on television
first of all is it done during the
middle of the day is the person standing
in a [ __ ] hallway you know you know
what [ __ ] that goddamn creative genius
if he's so [ __ ] smart if you get into
a better goddamn school than a rap a
whole Community College you know what
[ __ ] that issue alright sorry I just had
a [ __ ] anger flashback
alright how'd it get how to get the girl
advice advice dear bill how's it goin
I'm 21 years old I work with this girl
who I would really like to go out with
the girl is 29 years old with a 5 year
old what the [ __ ] I'm 21 years old I
work with the girl who I would really
like to go out with you should just [ __ ]
her I don't even need to read the rest
of this she's 29 area has a five year
old the [ __ ] is wrong with you you know
what I mean you're 21 years old you're
drafted in the first round and you're
immediately going to the fourth round
with somebody you know she's got a
five-year-old kid that's like drafted a
[ __ ] running back already blew out
his knee what's wrong with you oh he
actually writes I know after it okay so
he knows all right he goes I can't help
it though we flirt all the time at work
and seemed to really connect everyone
jokes so we are going out
whenever confronted with the possible
but the possibility from someone this
chick she says nothing and laughs but in
a good way so about two weeks ago I
eventually got the balls up to ask her
out to go do something but I think I
went about it the wrong way I switched
the conversation over to sex your
instincts are great sir but you're 21 so
you kind of fumbling through this is all
right he goes I asked her a hypothetical
question which your response was
something like I would go over to your
house and beat you up to which I said
why do you have to beat me up we could
do other things Jesus Christ dude what
do you Butthead we could do other things
uh uh I'm sorry
terrible impressions she goes she got
the gist and the conversation went on
for that went on like that for another
ten minutes getting nowhere so just
simply flirting about a week later with
my confidence hi I asked her out and she
said something like so when are we going
out oh I said so when are we going out
sorry guys I'm [ __ ] this whole thing
up let's regroup here huh so anyways
everything goes great a [ __ ] week
later I go up to I go so what are we
going out
she seems hesitant and she says I don't
know where would we go see right now you
already [ __ ] up this is how you [ __ ]
up all right all you want to do is [ __ ]
this girl okay and rather than coming
out and saying it you danced around it
you know you just got to come out and
say it you got to just tell them what
your [ __ ] intentions are might say
listen I want to [ __ ] you
you dope you know you you got yourself
halfway into you basically told her hey
I'm gonna take you out to a movie and
make you feel like I really like you
then I'm gonna [ __ ] bang you and
never call you again you basically said
that to her so now she's sitting there
she's grilling you where are we gonna go
and you were like I don't know we could
go somewhere to eat you could come over
to my house we could do anything you
choose
see this is the thing you don't have any
tact you went from we could go out
somewhere to eat there should have been
something else there should have been
something else and then maybe you say
your house you don't go from some ego or
my house you know you basically you're
in Leatherface mode here you just come
and fly you'll open it in a panel door
coming in just [ __ ] dragging her in
the back you can't be like that
alright so well I might have just
finished this [ __ ] thing you get to
his question I could never get a
straight answer so for the past week
when I see her I say so what do you want
to go she replies every time I don't
know it's really bumming me out now she
seems to be less friendly every time I
see her yeah dude cuz you keep [ __ ]
tightening the noose around your neck so
is there something I could say to her
that could get me straight a straight
answer or anything I could possibly do
to just know where I stand with this
girl I admit a very inexperienced with
girls and I don't know how to really go
about this isn't that great so you admit
that after I sit there and [ __ ] trash
you well if you're still listening if I
haven't beaten you down creatively here
I think your move is is you just stop
asking her just stop asking her continue
to be really [ __ ] friendly and then
you know wait for the Christmas party
and try to bang her then I don't know
this is what I would tell you just keep
doing what you're doing keep putting it
out there and eventually through trial
and error you're gonna figure out what
to do
alright I don't know if you got the
skills at this point to bring this one
into the boat I think it's already it's
off the hook it's gone I think you kind
of heard of Felix I thinks you should I
think she actually liked you liked you
and she thought you felt the [ __ ]
same basically because that you flirted
too long and you got to know each other
so then you know cuz women are more
developed emotionally when it comes to
that she actually went down more of a a
I think I have feelings for this guy and
right as she started giving into that
you know she's 29 she's got a kid maybe
you're gonna be the knight in shining
armour to get her out of that [ __ ]
single mother [ __ ] you
with the you know we could get a tray of
macaroni and hang out my bedroom get out
right there she's like ah another guy
just trying to bag me that's how I ended
up with the five year old so you gotta
understand dude she's already she's
already done this you know five years
old she was 24
she probably banged that Matthew
McConaughey type character from Dazed
and Confused he [ __ ] knocked her up
and took her took off completely [ __ ]
her life so she's a little gun-shy but
the end of the day she is a human being
and they do need affection and that type
of thing and women are down for just
[ __ ] if you present it in the proper
way which you haven't I don't think in
this one you can what you got to do is
yeah I would don't whatever you do don't
stop talking to it just be nice to her
hey how's it going blah blah blah just
don't [ __ ] ask her out again and see
if she makes a [ __ ] move if she makes
a move oh jesus this is like this point
how far down the [ __ ] you are this
is like trying to snip the right wire
without having the thing the device blow
up in your face okay so let's let's play
this scenario so then she comes to
you'll be like hey you know I thought we
were gonna go out you never asked me
anymore then you could be like yeah well
I don't know I just kind of got a vibe
like I kind of turned you off or
whatever you know and that's what you do
be like you know you were right you were
right look you're in a different
situation to me I'm just 21 I was just
looking to have some fun and I realized
that that you know I shouldn't have done
that blah blah blah and maybe then she
give you think well I could have some
fun and then maybe you could go that
route you know I know I think your best
bet is to try to get a drunk at the
Christmas party
[Laughter]
I had a [ __ ] dumb why would you
listen to me
anyway so let's plow ahead here yeah
dude let it go let it go just rub one
out before you go into work so you just
[ __ ] totally chill just have that
chill just cover that [ __ ] James Bond
you know just totally relax ll love you
know whatever maybe it'll happen plenty
of fish in the sea you know plenty of
fish in the sea okay but in the meantime
dude what [ __ ] I lost all point of this
you're 21 she's 29 who gives a [ __ ] you
know Jesus Christ you know it's actually
you trying to lay a 29 year old is
really gonna help you with [ __ ] women
your own age cuz it's not nearly gonna
be it's [ __ ] difficult I can tell you
this this is the best advice let me give
you with women if they're drunk and
they're drinking red wine do not kiss
them there's nothing worse than [ __ ]
Merlot breath all right take her home
and just [ __ ] bend her over which he
goes to kiss she just grab a head full
of her hair you know pull it you just
hold it let her feel your power but not
be intimidated by it
you know she'll feel safe and be [ __ ]
turned on all at the same time turn that
[ __ ] over you bend her over your mush
your face right near Forman grill and
you have at it but no to know
circumstances you know when their teeth
you know what it'll it makes your teeth
look like when you're drinking red wine
it's just [ __ ] horrific speaking of
which speaking of which the the [ __ ]
YouTube video of the week I'm gonna warn
you guys because it's the holiday season
[Music]
listen the [ __ ] this video is
absolutely disgusting this video in a
weird way if it was to be sold in a
video store which really don't exist
anymore it would be in the two girls one
cup section all right now it's not
nearly as lewd is it over-the-top too
disgusting is that video but it is every
bit is gross it's
virgins kissing for the first time
they're both in the 20s they're at a
wedding and they go in for the kiss and
I cannot [ __ ] explain what it is that
they're doing first of all I I really
hate watching people hardcore kiss I
hate it I don't like it at movies I
don't like it in pornos pornos our
movies bill you know what I mean
mainstream movies I don't like it in
pornos I don't like it when I'm walking
down the street I think it is [ __ ]
disgusting to watch to people good
looking or not good looking to [ __ ]
have at it it's [ __ ] gross give
yourself quick little smooch that's it
but to sit there with your [ __ ]
tongues down jammed out each other's
throats
it's the most [ __ ] repulsive thing
you could possibly do sorry I don't know
so you compiled you compiled that with
the fact that these are two virgins and
basically watching them go at it leave
them out you're that movie alien
remember when it's little mouth would
come out of its big mouth
just imagine two aliens kissing with
that little mouth that's what it looked
like they look like they were eating
each other's faces
it's [ __ ] that the whole thing is
[ __ ] disgusting and the fact that
they're in love so they're passionately
kissing in this horrific way and totally
[ __ ] repressed and just the whole
[ __ ] thing and the fact that they got
married there's another way that just
[ __ ] freaks you out it's the most
disgusting video I've ever seen so I'm
warning you so please do not complain to
me it's not my fault I didn't make the
video I have warned you good luck
alright let's [ __ ] plow ahead here
Lovelace in Alaska Lovelace in Alaska
that sounds like a ripoff of that Tom
Hanks movie love the podcast and need
some advice I'm at 33 33 year-old guy
who lives in Fairbanks Alaska I did a
gig up that way Chilkoot Charlie's way
back in the day I think was in Juneau
though I don't remember anyways Alaska I
need your take on what the [ __ ] I should
do when it comes to being here I moved
up here with my girlfriend of four years
I gotta hit pause dude I got a [ __ ]
clear out the [ __ ]
you're not gonna listen to this hold on
all right I'm back sorry what the [ __ ] I
should do up here in Fairbanks Alaska I
moved up here with my girl of four years
and got dumped about six months ago yeah
cuz she saw that dick up there
I am they have to fly women and up there
yeah dude you Alaska is basically the
[ __ ] you ever see that movie The
Dirty Dozen but it's all those guys
hanging there than that one night they
bring it all those [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what Alaska's like so anybody goes I've
been up here solo the [ __ ] pieced out
and and I'm thoroughly convinced I'll
remain single if I continue to run
reside in this [ __ ] planet hoth sub
Arctic wasteland of horribly ugly chicks
the guy to girl ratio in Fairbanks which
with the military base is about one
point five three seven million to one
you probably think I am a whiny [ __ ]
but now by now and are thinking I should
just move the hell on yeah that's what I
was thinking the problem is my job I'm a
firefighter/paramedic here and
absolutely love my job but when I leave
the guys at the station to go home I
feel like Luke Skywalker all stranded in
the blizzard I don't even have a
tauntaun to hack apart but [ __ ] if it's
not grinded on me I don't drink and hate
bars and [ __ ] the web sites what do I do
bill well you just basically walled
yourself off so like I can bounce back
down to the lower 48 that's the states
down here for you people never been to
Alaska that's what they call us down
here the lower 48 and pick up a gig like
the one I have here please hit me with
some advice love the show and hope you
come back to Alaska sometime ah dude you
got to get out there you can't you have
to go to the bars I would be on Facebook
you know trying to [ __ ] fly in some
[ __ ] from the Yukon Territory so you
got to work extra hard for this I don't
know what to tell you cuz you basically
listen my advice was obviously well why
don't you get out of there
you know they have fires in every other
state they have plenty of fires down
here you know
there's a bunch of gorgeous women out
here in Los Angeles just waiting for you
know how much they would love you if you
came down here as a firefighter
how much more [ __ ] interesting that
is if you [ __ ] went into one of these
Hollywood buzz and everybody there's an
actor director producer comedian or that
bull she come in you're a firefighter
you're actually unbelievably interesting
like holy [ __ ] a real person with a real
job as opposed to us with our [ __ ]
phony jobs I think you do I write down
here this is what I would do if I was
you I hit the bars I'd hit the [ __ ]
social networks and I would get my
resume together and I would send it out
to all 48 states you know why don't you
[ __ ] just totally turn the tables and
submit it to Hawaii why don't you go
live down there bang one of those
gorgeous [ __ ] Honolulu chicks oh by
the way I did a gig out brain this
weekend and I believe it was the first
show Saturday night there was a chick in
the front [ __ ] row all right I
thought she had on booty shorts somebody
told me in the end that it was actually
a really short skirt and she had on
these [ __ ] you know those riding
boots like he just stepped off a [ __ ]
pony that these girls are wearing
nowadays she had those [ __ ] things on
she was basically wearing the Pretty
Woman outfit she had these unbelievably
[ __ ] perfect thickness tan [ __ ]
thighs right in the front row and she's
with her guy okay and I'm sitting in my
head going why not [ __ ] with this guy
let his girl dress like that and sit in
the front row
doesn't he know I won't be trying to
look up her skirt and it's gonna [ __ ] up
my show oh yeah I'm only a guy what the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do it like the
amount of energy I had to use during
that show and my dick is just talking to
me the host show don't know maybe this
is one of these weird guys that want you
to go [ __ ] his girl yeah maybe that's
what it is blah blah blah that I told a
couple off
jokes and I saw that she was a good girl
but she was dressed like a [ __ ] like
this girl is a [ __ ] champ goddamn
thoroughbred and I don't know what the
[ __ ] point of that story was but it
was absolute torture to not sit there
and [ __ ] look at her and you know
something I was sitting there going do I
address it or do I not address it and
then I immediately started thinking
about Patrice my great friend who passed
away and I was going [ __ ] man he
wouldn't he could have done a [ __ ]
hour on this [ __ ] and yeah you know what
I actually kind of stumbled in there's
something I wasn't sure if I was gonna
bring it up if I could but uh yeah a
great friend Patrice O'Neal passed away
man and we're all absolutely [ __ ]
devastated and I'm gonna try not to get
emotional here but he has a he has a DVD
called elephant in the room makes a
great Christmas gift and it would really
help out his mom and he also has a new
CD out on iTunes called mr. P and if you
guys could do me a huge favor
do you want to repay me for the podcast
on any level could you please buy that
man's work cuz I gotta tell you about
that guy no joke is the funniest [ __ ]
dude I ever met in my life and it's not
even close it's not even close and you
can't even that dude was so funny
like even his stand-up work only just
captures like a sliver of how [ __ ]
funny that guy was that guy I'm telling
you like him walking in to a deli to buy
a newspaper was funnier than most
comedians I ever met and it's just it's
just [ __ ] awful I'm still in shock
that he's he's not here anymore
and I don't know when the time's right
I'll be telling some some of his stories
because I'm telling you I can tell you
this there's not gonna be another one
and that's the thing that probably hurts
the most is that there's no [ __ ] way
I'm ever gonna meet someone like that
again in my life all right okay no
crying on the podcast here we go plowing
ahead so if you guys could
[ __ ] do that for me I would really
appreciate it
yeah all right so here we go push it
down bill push it down YouTube videos of
the week we got we got a great one the
Thanksgiving am I really gonna do
YouTube videos after that whatever we'll
have them up in the [ __ ] mm podcast
that's the podcast for this week the MB
mm podcast calm please visit that and we
have a donation button and all that but
I [ __ ] all of that just by Patrice
O'Neal's work share it with other people
because people really should know what a
genius that guy was one of a kind and
I'm gonna miss him all right that's the
podcast I'll talk to you guys next week
see
you